the Midland City of Coventry population
almost 350
000 at the last census but with net
migration passing 600 000 it gives you a
sense of just how many people came to
the country last year towards double a
reasonably sized British City
International students account for more
than 200 000 of those arrivals this
group have come from all over the world
from Singapore to India and Morocco to
study at the University of Warwick
why did you want to come to the UK to
study are you experiencing a very very
different lifestyle you know do you
think most people who've come to study
from abroad will stay in the UK when
they finish their courses I know most
people that I know for my course in
third year final year have got their
grad job or Masters in the UK so I would
say yes most most part yeah they will
stay
over a third of the University's student
population are currently from overseas
its highest ever level
but whatever the upside there are
questions which we all remember people
were asking on the lead up to brexit
which we're hearing again in Coventry
how many more houses do we have to build
how many more
are they going to be putting in the
hospitals are they going to be putting
more surgeries so that's my main concern
how we're going to be able to cope
because we're not really coping now
aren't we next we meet Ricky who works
in a warehouse to be honest he seems
despondent and doesn't buy the
government's argument that so much
migration is needed to fill jobs I've
tried to get into work in different
places and all it is now is agency
minimum wage I'm ready should we
concentrating on local people getting
them in training them up so with
unprecedented numbers of people coming
to the UK it's hard to square why some
companies are struggling to recruit like
this Veterinary Diagnostics firm which
has been advertising for a pathologist
for a year so is the problem that this
country is not doing enough to grow its
own Talent
possibly yes it is you know it is very
sad because there is a high need of that
and there's no incentive for people to
you know become a specialist at the
moment
the government says it's restricting the
rights of relatives to come with some
Visa holders and it remains committed to
reducing overall net migration but its
pledge to deliver control of borders
means the stakes on migration are higher
than ever East Holland Sky News Coventry